hey guys welcome back to the evan
caitlin podcast the podcast where
personality types are made up and your
question and your answers don't matter
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah maybe i don't know we're gonna find
out i don't know one thing that i
haven't told katelyn okay so to in
today's podcast we're gonna be taking a
personality test it's the 16 types it's
the myers-briggs
um test but one thing i haven't told
kaitlyn is a long time ago
for my very first internship i took a
personality test the same one
i was so hopeful it was gonna be the
same one and i was gonna compare like
are my answers gonna be completely
different but the one i took way back in
the day
it was like yellow blue it was four
types in a way but so this one's a four
types kind of
i don't know how it relates the one the
one i took like
oh gosh this was nine years ago
it's like i'm not sure how to relate it
but it's like yellow blue red
green and that's a very bad pie chart it
just says yellow
you're 41 yellow i don't know what
yellow means i don't know what it is
so it has an explanation that says the
relating socializer
the harmonizer well here let's let's
we can compare your results and see if
there's any like overlapping words
let's not get into your old one yet i
think we should jump into the new one
okay and so the reason we're doing this
is we actually get uh asked about it a
decent amount
people trying to like guess our
personality types like oh i think you're
a
intj i don't know i don't know why i
always
remember intj always remember intj maybe
maybe that's like a common one a lot of
people are intjs i don't know
but everyone like people will throw out
guesses
yeah and i don't actually know and i
think each letter stands for something
like um n is intuitive t
is thinking j is judging
f is feeling observant is s
why is it not o and p is prospecting
why is observant s maybe like it spelled
a bad word when it was o
oh yeah so they had to like put in
another letter yeah
well to give an overview of um the four
categories and then we might look into
the four
subtypes within those categories the
first are the the analysts
they're intuitive and thinking
personality types known for their
rationality
impartiality and intellectual excellence
okay then we have diplomats intuitive
and feeling personality types known for
their empathy diplomatic skills and
passionate idealism
then there's the sentinels observant and
judging personality types known for
their practicality and focus on order
security and stability
and then explorers observant and
prospecting personality types known for
their spontaneity ingenuity
and flexibility those are four
categories and they each have
four smaller categories before we even
look at the smaller categories i'm
curious about this
because like we're gonna be fit into one
of these
categories and i think it's really tough
because in me
i see mainly exploring
diplomat and analysis but a lot
a lot in the exploring category i think
you're gonna be an explorer
and i think i'm gonna be a sentinel so
yours
will be the spontaneity ingenuity and
flexibility and mind will be focused on
order security and stability
but it's like we are also definitely
like diplomats in a lot of ways
and we oh my gosh we analyze so much we
analyze ourselves
we analyze others we dislike that's true
i don't know actually right well so so
here's an interesting thing oh nps if
you're listening to this
yeah um we are actually gonna have our
screen
shared on the youtube version of this
podcast
so if you typically listen this might be
one that you want to look at if you want
to actually see the categories we're
looking at
um somehow i don't know maybe we'll put
it in front of us maybe our heads will
be blocking it
maybe we'll shoot us down or something
yeah maybe we'll shrink us um
so did you want to look at the yeah
let's look at the actual like
breakdown of them so the analysts inside
of the analyst category
there's the should we should we do that
i don't know that's gonna be that
interesting to listen to
okay let's get that there's 16 of them
you know
i think just the four overall categories
i i will say one
note of interest looking at the
categories
is in the bottom one the explorer the
one that i think evan falls into
yeah it's interesting because
the categories are like masters of tools
charming artists
um entrepreneurs and entertainers
and if i think about our business tools
art entrepreneur entertainer
that's what we would fit in for the
business but like i feel like
that's not gonna be me i don't know yeah
i don't think that we're gonna be
sentinels i might
you think i'm very orderly the like
logistician
practical and fact-minded individuals
who relate whose
related ability cannot be doubted i
don't know
or maybe we'll be diplomats maybe we'll
be the diplomats no
we're not going to be diplomats analysts
intj
is the architect imaginative and
strategic thinkers with a plan for
everything that's the one i always hear
about
uh i think we should just jump into it
let's just something to it i i'm gonna
be taking it at the same time that
caitlyn is taking it so we're both gonna
be taking the test
all right so the first question is you
enjoy
vibrant social events with lots of
people
see these things are so difficult
because pretend it's not
these times these strikes no no no yeah
i can do that but like the thing is
you enjoy vibrant social events with
lots of people for how long
and how frequently i do enjoy them but
spaced out well then i think people are
in the middle
i think if you like enjoy them all the
time for long times
then it's like strongly agree and also
what's my life situation okay
am i am i like is it summer and i don't
have any responsibilities or no
it's life now life now oh yeah it's now
it is it is right now okay i'm gonna do
the
the like slightly agree i'm gonna do
slightly two i'm gonna so okay just so
you guys know we're talking about
there's a neutral and then there's three
levels of agree
and three levels of disagree i'm gonna
go
the second most extreme disagree you
know what i i think that
i think that i'm like thinking about
this more with lots of people
i don't like lots of people
i like vibrant social events with small
amounts small small groups yeah
then maybe you're in the middle i'm
trying to think like what would be
what would count as lots of people like
acl
yeah or or like a party like a large
party i would think like i'm gonna do
slightly disagree
i think i'm actually gonna do slightly
disagree too i think in instead of the
like farther medium disagree okay it's
okay so we're in the same spot on that
next question oh you often spend
time exploring unrealistic yet
intriguing ideas you are 100
strongly the strongest agree there is
yeah i'm gonna put myself neutral like i
can go down a rabbit hole
i might be slightly disagree what do you
think i am oh
you can put purposeful time into it
but you have to actively do it i find
myself doing it
accidentally accidentally and all the
time
that is like so much yeah
i'm i'm actually gonna put slightly
disagree like just because our time is
so valuable these days i feel like
i won't i'll do it but only if it's like
research for a project that we might do
and then that's
then that's not not really i mean it
could be unrealistic
no but then that's focused study time
yeah you know
yeah i'm slightly different caitlin will
often look over at me and i'm just
staring off into space
she's like what are you thinking of and
i'm like oh you know just thinking about
how like we could use batteries to rig
up to this motor to do
like and she's like when would we ever
do that
or evan's like i was on this twitter
thread and then i clicked on this
person's profile
and i wanted to see what kind of videos
they did i looked at their videos and i
was thinking about this and i'm like
that's so many steps
like i would have stopped myself way
earlier in that
process and now evan all of a sudden
like knows the backstory of this random
youtuber i like
i like collecting i like collecting
stuff oh i like talking like stories
information knowledge
resources all of that anyways it's not
that i don't but my practicality
prevents me from doing it
awesome yeah okay next question your
travel plans
more are more likely to look like a
rough list of ideas than a detailed
itinerary oh so
disagree yeah we're pretty detailed with
our travel plans we're fairly detailed
i'm a strongly disagree and it's i'm
gonna do that
disagree it's not that we have to
require like a crazy itinerary and stick
to it but
when we're traveling we don't want to
waste time on vacation
doing research and like oh like that
doesn't mean that we're busy all the
time well yeah
this is a great place to relax we'll
spend a whole day just there
but like we're gonna look up all the
things to do we're gonna
look up all the good restaurants we're
gonna we're gonna like have a
pre-book anything that needs to be
pre-booked we're gonna like download
offline all of the maps in the area and
we're going to start
everything so we can navigate there
without internet just because like
vacation time is so valuable you don't
want to be doing research you don't want
to be like
on the beach researching like a good
place to eat no
do that when you're at home yeah
you know but we also leave room for
impromptu stuff
and we do that a lot so maybe i am the
second most excited but
but we but like your travel plans not
your traveling
oh yeah that's true travel plan this is
all about the plan
yeah okay you often think about what you
should have said in the conversation
long after it's taken place
i i do that but not much but this is
this is the the
this is another tough thing about this
personality test we don't interact with
other people much yeah when we did
i did think about what i should have
said but when it's the two of us
we're always around and we always like
will revisit a conversation if we like
hey you know what that conversation we
had like a few days ago
i've thought more about it and i have
more insights that i want to share with
you so we just
talk yeah i think like that's something
that i would occasionally do in high
school or college
yeah but not a ton not really
i'm gonna be neutral i'm gonna be pretty
like medium disagree okay
if your friend is sad about something
your first instinct to support them
emotionally
not try to solve their problem
it's interesting my first my
brain i think goes to water solutions
but i know that that
is probably not what they want so my
brain will sometimes start thinking of
solutions but that's not what i'll bring
up
i'm gonna probably be neutral on this
too because i i i
at the top it says don't be neutral
because that won't
lend itself to determining your
personality
you know because neutral is like
doesn't put you into any camp you know
what i mean
yeah if all your answers are neutral
you're not going to get a good you're
not going to get a good read on like
your personality so i want to
okay i'm going to go back i i think you
are slightly on the problem-solving side
i'm
slightly on the problem side side i'm
gonna
say i
i think i'm a medium agree
on the supporting them emotionally even
if my brain will try to go to solve
their problems
like but see that's the thing too my
brain goes to solve the problems but i'm
i often catch myself and my logic takes
over like
they might just need support also like
you know
through learning with with you and you
know talking with you
i'll i'll often ask like if you're upset
like i'll often ask like do you want to
talk about it or do you want my help
i think you're on the i would put you at
a medium
either a light disagree or a medium
disagree
yeah because it's about your instincts
not your actions yeah
i mean my instinct is also to support
them emotionally even if i'm coming up
with backup solutions
to the problem in case they ask i think
i'm on the emotional
support side i'm gonna actually go back
to the the question before this you
often think about what you should have
said in conversation long after it's
taken place i'm gonna do
slightly agree you know what's funny you
just went back to a conversation
and you rethought it you changed your
answer
okay um so i'm gonna put myself what did
i say medium
agree i'm gonna do medium agree on the
supporting support okay well this is
weird
oh no no we're at the same place people
can rarely upset you i'm gonna be
strongly disagree yeah people can upset
me people can upset me
because i think we we both care about
what people think
yeah i don't know if i'm strongly
disagree or medium disagree okay oh my
god i think i might be medium disagree
because there's also a lot that like
we don't let it get to us in a way we
try not to but we do really care
yeah i think medium is great okay next
10 through we talk about this a lot but
i'm glad we talked about this this is
the interesting part
just answering it isn't it you often
rely on other people to be the ones to
start a conversation and keep it going
oh that's me
i'm gonna do i'm gonna do strongly
disagree i'm gonna do strongly and
i'll do i'm pretty strongly agree i'm
not i'm not
i'm not the best at small talk medium
what do you think
i would be either medium agree or
strongly agree i'd say medium
because like you can't you can do it you
just don't like i don't like it
okay i'll do medium agree yeah what do
you think should i either strongly
disagree or medium disagree no you're
strongly disagree you're really good at
conversations all right
you have to temporarily put your plans
on hold if you have to temporarily put
your plans on hold you make sure it is
your top priority to get back on track
as soon as possible
i think you might be strongly yeah i
think i'm a strongly agree
uh should i be neutral slightly agree or
slightly disagree no you're in the agree
side yeah
it depends on how important the plans
are
i think if it's something you're
planning for it's probably important
i'll be slightly
slightly agree i think you also have to
like
yes you could say like oh what if the
plan is just i wanted
to go to taco bell for lunch and no i
can't but it's like that's not really
you know like i think like
oh we had we were going to do a video
today but then
our ac broke you know or our computer
power supply broke that actually did
happen my computer's in the shop
and the ac broke also yeah that happened
too um
i i think that my my issue with this is
if you have to temporarily put your
plans on hold you make sure it is your
top priority to get back on track
as soon as possible i just i'm not like
crazy about as soon as possible and
that's why i'm gonna do this
slightly agree okay just because for me
it's not like
i try not to like put crazy pressure on
like the time of it
well yeah but as soon as possible
doesn't mean that that could be like as
soon as
it it's that could be like impractically
soon
yeah as soon as possible is this like
when this is
possible yeah that's kind of like
um words subjective
we are recording this in the morning
have you been able to notice
how good our words are i do have my
coffee this morning oh you mean our
coffee
hey next question you rarely worry if
you made a good impression on someone
you met
oh i disagree i do worry about that
hi baby you want to hang out jubi's here
it depends on if i like the person
[Laughter]
i you rarely really worry i'm gonna
do a i'm gonna do a light disagree i'm
gonna do a light disagree just cause
generally it's like sometimes i worry
about it
but um generally i feel like
it was a at least a decent impression
also it's kind of like i'm kind of at
the point where i am who i am
i'm not going to change if they don't
like me then
you know that's right you're not yeah
you're true
i think that when i was maybe i'm
slightly agree yeah when i was younger
i did worry about that more but now i'm
like look
i am who i am
yeah that's true actually it was
something
i'm gonna do slightly agree yeah i'm
gonna just slightly agree too yeah
i don't wanna do neutral cause that like
gives you nothing yeah i think i think
it's tough because you think back to
like your whole life you think back to
your whole life but this is about who
you are now yeah
not who you are throughout your life
yeah i was thinking like
through the eight different schools i
went to and being a new kid all the time
well like who we are now it's like oh
yeah if you don't like us
well i mean like in in a way we're
putting ourselves out there to hundreds
of thousands and millions of people and
if people like we get comments
fairly frequently like not fairly
frequently but like we see them of like
you guys are annoying and i'm like sorry
we're not gonna change who we are
yeah for for y'all we're just who we are
and that's that so yeah i think uh
yeah absolutely all right it would be a
challenge for you to spend
the whole weekend by yourself without
feeling bored i am
strongly disagree so
that's who i've been throughout my
entire life yeah and that's still who i
am now
i mean i would if you if you had to
leave for a weekend
i would miss you yeah i don't would much
not
i would much rather be with you but i
would be busy
i could do a billion bajillion things
yeah and i wouldn't feel bored i've
rarely ever in my life felt bored
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna strongly
disagree here too there's too much to do
to feel bored
you are a more of a detail oriented than
a big picture person
oh i am do you think i'm strongly
disagree or medium disagree
i think you're a medium disagree because
you do
like to think about details you just
think about them secondary
yeah and i would i be as strongly agree
not not the super strongly but like the
medium strongly agree i think
yeah let's do slight medium and strong
for like that because there's there's
three slight slight they're slightly
green medium and green strongly
yeah so i would be a i think a medium
agree i think a medium degree
and i think that we balance each other
out in that way very well
mm-hmm yeah you are very affectionate
with people you care about
strongly agree i think you're well i
mean with me
like but you know when we saw our
friends i would like we do
give them all a hug and like you know
i i think i'll say strong am i am i a
medium agree
i'm a pretty strong agree like family
and friends you're you're medium or
strong
whichever you feel in your heart i think
i'm probably
i think you're strong yeah
strong strong 20
you have a careful and methodical
approach to life
careful and methodical i'm
uh slight disagree
i think i might be slight agree yeah
yeah
it's like you might be medium medium
agree
yeah i think i am i agree pulling you
into like the wild side that's true
and you you are coming along with me but
on one hand i'm like
like to do stuff like live stream or
start a youtube channel like there's
there is a certain amount of like chaos
just
inherent in that but i still do have a
pretty careful and methodical approach
to things in general yeah i'm a medium
agree
medium agree yeah i love the way you
make coffee by the way thank you it's so
good
i didn't know you would be drinking it i
should have made more
you are still bothered by the mistakes
you made a long time ago
um not really this is something that i
have evolved with over time
it used to bother me more but at this
moment
no i'd say medium disagree i'm a medium
disagree also
because you know we are who we are
because of our past and i like where
we're at
and we couldn't be where we're at
without our past the mistakes and the
successes and
yeah you know and like mistakes
like if you didn't make the mistake
when you did it you might make it later
when the stakes are higher
yeah like it's kind of like when we were
making youtube videos i wanted to
you know like work with sponsors as soon
as possible so we could like
fail or succeed or like learn all the
hard lessons yeah but it was a matter of
like
like very small amounts of money and
like
a smaller audience call our audience if
we did the ad
wrong or whatever you know yeah so like
make your mistakes
early yeah i'm yeah i think i don't feel
good about it i think we're both medium
disagree
at parties and similar events you can
mostly be found farther away from the
action
it's interesting because it depends
because like it depends on
how what percentage of the party is our
friends exactly
because like back in like the college
days yeah we were part of the group that
was like putting together
the party we would be pretty center and
you did more partying during college
than i did
i kind of joined in after college yeah
but like right now if i think about
um like going to like content creator
events or you know before we were doing
youtube going to like work
parties i'd be kind of like not in the
corner
you know but not the center of attention
kind of medium
these days i'm gonna do
slightly disagree but also because
another there's another thing that we've
done
is like when we when we still went out
and stuff we just stopped going to
things that didn't have a high enough
percentage of our friends
yeah and then we were in the middle
because it was just our friends and
stuff yeah yeah
yeah i'm gonna do slightly disagree also
this isn't a core personality trait for
us i think
but trying to trying to give the best
answers they can with
with a yeah it's not like we're like
partying all the time no you have to be
at the center of the attention
no no no okay next you often find it
difficult to relate to people who let
their emotions
guide them strongly disagree
because we're pretty good at relating
yeah i
i don't really whether it's emotions or
logic i don't
like you know leading people i don't
really have a
hard time understanding
why they're choosing to do what they
choose this is a medium or strong
disagree
yeah i feel like it's a pretty strong
disagreement i'm gonna go i'm gonna go
strong
yeah it's like i might not agree but i
understand it yeah i understand it
yeah we can empathize well i guess this
is like relate to them
oh so it's not really agree or
understand it's not
understand oh no it's relate
yeah this does not understand uh
understand
it's relate so that means you're similar
yeah that means you're similar
oh oh that that changes it a lot change
it because i
i mean my emotions are part of what
guide me but i use a lot of logic too i
use a lot
of logic so maybe i'm like lightly
disagree
do you find it difficult to relate
to people oh i use logic but that
doesn't mean i can't relate to people
who use their emotions okay
very uh actually i don't know because i
might i might be i might be
slight i might be slight agreed too
because relate means you're on the same
page
yeah and i don't necessarily relate to
that
even if i understand it yeah we don't
relate to it but
i'm more on the side of using logic than
emotion like we feel our emotions and we
think that they're important but in the
end it's often
logic yeah i mean just think of like
like some of the stuff we've taken on
the emotion is like oh that's a scary
thing let's not
let's not try it that's a new and scary
thing but the logic is like oh if we try
it we could learn a lot
you know
when looking for a movie to watch you
spend ages browsing the catalog
how is this a personality type i think
it maybe has to do with like
um how much you analyze stuff
i mean we watch movies like twice a year
i would say slight or medium agree
i would say slight agree
it's so we don't really like movies too
much
what i will say is um the reason i think
slight agree
actually i might do medium agree like
we're not going to watch a movie
if we don't already know it's going to
be a good movie
typically how we determine that is just
like we've heard enough people either in
real life or on the internet say it's a
good movie
so it's not that we're actively spending
time browsing through a catalog
like i would spend you slight agree
because i think how
people how the quiz people were like
wording this is like
you sit down and you like click through
like a bajillion movies on like the
movie thing and you just spend more time
browsing than watching yeah we kind of
like sit down at our computers
google a whole bunch of movies we pull
up our list of movies that people have
mentioned to us
and then we like so it's a shorter
process because we're only looking at a
list of like oh here's a handful of
movies people have
are talking about right now or people
have mentioned us yeah yeah
slight agree yeah you can stay calm
under a lot of pressure
i'm less calm than you under pressure
i'll do slight agree
i'm gonna do slight disagree like
i can maybe come off as calm but i'm
probably free
what do you think would i be your back
is like sweating a little bit oh yeah
i definitely get sweaty i think that
like out of like at events if we're
gonna give a talk and stuff i think i am
more calm than you
uh yeah i get i get nervous but it's not
outward
yeah i think i think i'm a slight
disagreement i'm slight agree
okay when in a group of people oh my
gosh 30 i know
we're halfway through the podcast i
think we need to like go like but at the
same time i'm glad that we are
discussing it because like on that last
one
the word relate yeah changed our
interpretation exactly
we're only going to take this
personality test once yeah might just be
a longer podcast
might just be a longer podcast okay when
in a group of people you don't know you
have no problem jumping right into their
conversation oh god strongly disagree
strongly disagree oh i'm gonna do
slight disagree
yeah you can do it you just i can't do
it don't enjoy it but like
jumping into their conversation yeah
it's like if there's a
if there's a circle it's hard to breach
the circle y'all
it's really hard i can do it i'm just
gonna do slight disagree
nightmare when you sleep your dreams
tend to be
bizarre bizarre bizarre and fantastical
you're like a full agree but like i'm a
medium or strong
but like they're fantastical they're not
really bizarre
well i think it just means i'm like in a
movie and i have powers or like i'm a
spy
or like i'm disabling a bomb they're not
really bizarre
because like you have had slightly more
like
bizarre that's true like you're in like
this crazy cave and there's creatures
and there's like
hanging things and stuff like that mine
are like
creepy dreams yeah caitlyn has more
bizarre
but more than the creepy dreams well i
used to have almost all creepy
dreams um or like kind of bizarre dreams
but these days most of my dreams are
just like practical stuff
in my dreams so like worrying about the
supervisor
oh yeah i have bad dreams that like the
other cats are getting into the house
and i have to project protect a jube
from the other cats
and i don't want her to get mixed up and
accidentally like swap cats
yeah okay do you think i'm strongly or
medium i think you're strongly i agree
that yours are bizarre and fantastical
and i'm i'm gonna do a slight
disagree because your your dreams have
like calmed down a little bit from the
bizarre it's just more of them tend to
be practical
or like stress related than like fantasy
or like bizarre yeah yeah
okay in your opinion it is sometimes
okay to step on others to get ahead in
life
strongly disagree strongly disagree rude
rude it is not okay to step on others
get ahead no no no
no no no you are dedicated and focused
on your goals
only rarely getting sidetracked
i'm pretty focused now at the same time
i often get sidetracked
but i am dedicated to the goals
but i'm also often so it's about you get
sidetracked and then you use those side
tracks to make new goals
yeah goals medium disagree and i think
i'm
medium agree or strong agree i don't get
sidetracked yeah yeah you're strong
agree
you're strong agree i like do not i'm
pretty laser focused
yeah you're right if you make a mistake
you tend to start doubting yourself
your abilities or your knowledge medium
disagree
yeah media or light or medium disagree
i think medium disagree it helps because
like we talk about things yeah
you know and then i don't doubt it as
much
when at a social event you rarely try to
introduce yourself to new people and
mostly talk to the ones you already know
agree
i'm gonna do medium agree on that too
i'm a strong agree on that like i
i can introduce myself to new people but
i'd rather just
focus on the relationships i kind of
already have established
yeah yeah i don't like going up to new
people it's scary
you usually lose interest in the
discussion when it gets philosophical
strongly disagree when it's with you
when it's with someone i care about
yeah i'm down to get into it yeah
and like if it's not someone you care
about does it often get philosophical no
you just really get philosophical with
like light acquaintances i don't know
yeah i'm going to say strongly disagree
i mean
maybe the definition of philosophical is
different but
i i think of it as thinking of like
bigger
when we've had like deeper discussion
with like our cousins or
like friends friends we like that
yeah we like that stuff yeah i like
philosophical conversations
you would never let yourself cry in
front of others i mean i don't like to
but i have
i already told my story about crying in
front of my boss
i'd say slight disagree for me
because like i mean the main person i
cry in front of is you when we're
watching sad
tv oh my gosh oh the one we were
watching oh oh
my emotions oh the emotions i'll do
medium distance i'm a medium disagree
too like i don't
necessarily want to but like um
it happens yeah you feel more drawn to
places with bustling and busy atmosphere
than to quiet
i mean it's like to go on vacation or to
live
i think i i tend to prefer like more
chill even though i do like the hustly
bustly stuff for like
sometimes on vacations like going to
like the like chiang mai night market
that was cool but like what i really
prefer is being on a secluded beach
yeah you know slight disagree
i'm gonna be a medium disagree
yeah i think medium disagreed too yeah
for the long
for the majority of my life i want to be
in quiet and intimate instead of
busy crazy and hustling yeah
you like discussing different views and
theories on what the world could look
like in the future
strong agree yeah
i like that stuff i like discussing
views and theories about future stuff
it's not necessarily all
always what the world could look like
because sometimes that's
the future of youtube or like oh yeah
that's the future of
content creation and stuff like that i
think that that counts
yeah then i strongly agree yeah
when it comes to making life-changing
choices you mostly mostly listen to your
heart rather than your head
medium disagree yeah
or maybe a slight disagree because like
at the same time i think it's like it's
on the choice
you know yeah because something is you
need your heart some things you need
your head
when it comes to life-changing choices
that means
like marriage or job
and stuff like that and both of those
were
heart life-changing choices
heart rather than your head i don't know
like yeah because
i tend to use logic but i feel like
if your heart isn't in it and you're
trying to like
bulldoze it with logic overrule the
heart
sometimes i will use logic to help me
get over like
fears but if i'm not
excited about a change
like i can use logic to like make myself
become more excited or make myself get
over fears
but i use the logic to manipulate my own
emotions
you know what i mean yeah to get my
emotions because it says when making
life-changing choices
most things most choices in life aren't
life-changing and we usually listen to
our head
but when it comes to life-changing
choices yeah i think like heart actually
a heart yeah i'm gonna be slight on the
heart side i'm gonna be slight on the
heart side too
that's so crazy like taking a moment and
actually thinking about the words that
are on the page
changed us from slight disagree to slide
agree yeah
i think that's very interesting you
cannot imagine your life
you cannot imagine yourself dedicating
your life to the study of something that
you cannot see
touch or experience i think i'm on the
agree side
yeah i mean because i like my efforts i
like to
i mean
personally i like for my time to turn
into something
tangible me too even if that quote
unquote tangible thing for us is like
a video that's still something that
lives on
so that's still some that's something
you can see and experience yeah
yeah i'm i'm uh um
strongly agreed that i cannot imagine my
self-dedicated my life to study
something i can't see touch or
experience
i i like b because i think if you
experience you can experience anything
yeah i don't know i mean maybe like if
you were studying history or something
um yeah you can't experience that
i was not i was not good at strong
student of history
no me neither by that i mean i didn't i
didn't enjoy it not that there's
anything bad with history studies
no it's just this is me personal too
many dates you know
20 dates and names i'll always strongly
agree to yeah
what if we end up being the same
personality type that wouldn't matter
we've been like
opposites on some things that's true you
usually prefer to get your revenge
rather than forgive
no strongly disagree yeah
on a lot of on so many things we're on
the same page but on some we are
opposite it's interesting
yeah you often make decisions on a whim
um that's pretty strong disagree on that
on a whim
um you often even even like deciding
what to eat we're like
should we want to have a mini meeting
about lunch what should we have for
lunch
would i be neutral because i don't i
don't think you make decisions on a whim
you think about things yeah i'm gonna be
slight disagree i'm a strong
disagreement
the time you spend by yourself often
ends up being more interesting and
satisfying than the time you spend with
other people
so like if we're saying by ourselves
does that mean
like to get like
because i'm going to be medium disagree
because
we are with each other we're with each
other yeah
yeah i'm going to put a strong disagree
and it's not that i
well maybe i'll put medium disagree
because it's not that i'm like a social
creature
but like i my time with you is more
interesting than time by myself
but we kind of like in our heads
consider like time with each other
like alone time
like we are a unit we are a unit and
that's weird
so we are we are an abnormality when it
comes to that
if we're thinking of that if we're
thinking of ourselves as a single person
then
well i mean there's still like it
depends on the social setting
if it's like a small group of close
people that can be nice sometimes
but typically i prefer to just be with
you
i'm gonna do see the time you spend by
yourself often ends up being more
interesting and satisfying the time you
spend with other people
only to medium disagree
yeah i'll do medium disagree i'll do a
slight disagree i'm sorry sometimes i'm
trying to like wrap my brain around what
am i
which which is the agree side and which
is the disagree side yeah
this is spending time by yourself is
more interesting i'm a
slight disagree yeah it's kind of like a
lot of these questions are like
the the yes is a no and the no is a yes
and everything it's like
you don't enjoy this yes or you do no
means do you know yeah you often put
special effort into interpreting
the real meaning or message of a song or
movie
not really not really medium disagree
medium disagree i used to look up like
there's a website about like song lyric
meanings and stuff but
not really anymore you always know
exactly what you want oh
slight disagree i don't know i might be
slight agree
you always know exactly what you want
well if you say
if if you say slight agree then i think
it's like you sometimes know
what you want like always and exactly
are very strong words so i feel like
you're only saying you always know
exactly what you want if you do the
strongest degree
but like in general like i kind of know
what my goals in life are yeah yeah
you're right
you know i was thinking about food
even then though even then yeah we are
pretty good
it's like we are pretty like like we
don't go out of our way to get food
that sounds better than whatever food is
convenient or close
yeah you know what i mean yeah it's like
we know it's what we want slide agree
i'm going to do a slight degree maybe
even a medium agree
go for it i'm going to do medium agree
no i'm going to do a slight
i don't degree know okay you rarely
think back on the choices you have made
and wonder what you could have done
differently
okay this is you rarely
so if you say agree that means you don't
do it medium agree
i'm going to do medium agree yeah i
don't think back on it too much
or sorry i'm going to do a light a no a
medium a medium agree
yeah because we talked about this
earlier a little bit yeah it's kind of
similar yeah
when in a public place you usually stick
to quieter less crowded areas this is
getting kind of repetitive yeah
it's like oh gosh what's up with all
this like talk of other people
okay yeah um medium agree
may be a strong agree in a public
no yeah that's like the grocery stores
libraries do you go to libraries often
oh we used to in college
that was a long time ago yeah what
public places do we go
restaurants we go wherever the waiter
puts us
the host puts us um
i'm just trying to like think of what
public place we would go to
even discounted covet yeah
i mean movie theaters you don't there's
it's all kind of the same
like a beach we would want quieter and
less crowded
yeah like a beach just trying to think
of
public places we would go we don't
go to like parks not really i'd say
strongly agree
i'm going to do a light agree just
because i don't
have to actively avoid crowds
you know yeah like like some people
really dislike
yeah so i'm gonna be like yeah we're not
as strong as some people
yeah so i'm gonna do like a medium agree
that i like the quieter and less crap
yeah because we need to think of
this is relative to other people you
know like in the spectrum yeah you're
right
i'm gonna move down to me yeah i might
even be a light like i don't
i don't mind like if the beach is
crowded it doesn't bother me that
much yeah we're still going to do it
we're still going to do it okay slight
i'm going to move this slide towards
like yeah so i agree yeah
now that we've talked about like it
needs to be relative to other people
yeah there are people
many more people that like are much more
picky about much more crowd averse
yeah you tend to focus on present
realities rather than future
possibilities
i focus on both
neutral present realities
more than future possibilities i might
be slightly i might be slightly disagree
i might be slightly agree like it might
slightly focus on the present more i
slightly focus on the future more i
think that kind of goes back to our like
i am slightly more detailed you're a
slightly more big picture yeah
yeah yeah yeah you often have a hard
time understanding other people's
feelings strongly disagree
strongly disagree yeah
when starting to work in a project you
prefer to make as many decisions up
front as possible
i strongly agree forget it i well it's
interesting
like when we are doing a video
sometimes we will purposefully not
like fully fully research certain parts
of it because it will make the video
more interesting
but i think that's kind of different but
we're still making a decision
like i'm just going to be slightly agree
i think you're strong
yeah i think i'm strong i'm just slight
when you know someone thinks highly of
you you also wonder how long it will be
until they become disappointed with you
sad
yeah i just do medium disagree
i'm a strong disagree that's not really
something we don't we don't put time and
thought into that
yeah you feel comfortable just walking
up to someone you find interesting and
striving
striking up a conversation strongly
disagree no
you could probably do it
someone someone you find
interesting
comfortable so it's like
if it's someone if it's someone that i
find interesting
and the opportunity to present itself
i'm probably going to do it
yeah you you probably will i mean like
the main thing i think of is i got maker
faires and stuff like that
i would too but i'm not comfortable i'm
not comfortable but i'm going to do it
yeah so okay maybe i'm
because i will do it too yeah because
you're you're going to do it so you're
not
i'm not a strong disagreement i think
i'm a medium disagree i still really
don't like it
i'm going to do i'm so very honest i
lightly agree because i do it
and you're more comfortable at it i'm
more comfortable i'm not like
super comfortable but i'm going to do it
yeah
right next 70 baby we're
blowing through this we're only 45
minutes into the body
you often drift away into daydreaming
about various ideas or scenarios
strongly agree yeah that's you
i'm not really
i don't really you need to actively do
it yeah
yeah i might set aside time to think
about it but i'm not
gonna just drift away i'm a medium
disagree
you look after yourself first and others
come in second
i'm gonna do a slight disagree do we
when it says yourself again does that
mean the two of us as a unit no
because i think that we often think of
each other yeah then i'm uh
then i'm a medium disagree i think
there's coming second but only like
with you you look after you yeah yeah
good stuff that's what that's why i did
slightly
that's what we just slightly disagree
because like it's it's
mainly just for each other
i'm gonna do a medium disagree yeah
even when you have planned a particular
daily routine you usually just end up
doing what you feel like at any given
moment
i'm a medium disagree like sometimes i
will change
i'm gonna do maybe i'm a strong disagree
i'm gonna do a
slight disagree because like if it
honestly if it was just myself doing
like
freelance like you know content creation
or like you know independent content
creation
i would float around more
then wouldn't you be agree yeah but like
that's not my reality
so i do end up sticking fairly well to
our daily routine
and it's not daily routine it's the plan
even if you have plans
yeah we don't really have we don't
really have a routine yeah
we have a very light routine uh
i'm i'm right in the middle of strongly
or like slightly either way
i'm going to do slightly agree yeah i
think what do you think i am a medium
disagree
medium or strong yeah i might be as
strong you might be a strong
i don't get as distracted yeah i think
sometimes
sometimes you'll like think of something
else but then you'll add it on the list
you know what i mean and then it's a
plan
i'm on the list but i
i think i'm a strong disagree
your mood can change very quickly
our mood is fairly steady i'm yeah our
mood is fairly steady
now there are certain things that can
trigger like a
a quick shift like if we get like a
disturbing email or like uh
something but like you know that's so
rarely it's yeah it's pretty rare it's
only like when something
causes a sudden like
increase in time pressure related stress
yeah it's like when we get like an email
from a sponsor like doing like some
crazy change and
we're like ah yeah so it's like your
mood can change very quickly
yes but does it change very quickly
frequently
no i think we're pretty i'm gonna say
like a medium disagree
yeah i'm gonna do medium disagree too
that's why we're pretty over even
yeah you often contemplate the reason
for human existence or the meaning of
life oh you're a strong degree
strong agree i think am i am i a strong
or a medium
i don't know if i pull you into it would
you do it if it wasn't for me like
pulling you into it like on a weekly
basis
i would but i don't know if i would do
it as much as you it's i guess what i'm
trying to think is like
yeah compared to you i i don't think
about it quite as much
but compared to the majority of people
which is what this test is against
yeah you're a medium yeah
you often talk about your own feelings
and emotions strong to each other
yeah strong agree yeah strong
stronks stronks
you've got detailed education or career
development plans stretching several
years into the future
agree but i'm medium
i mean i guess for me though not really
because
of what we do it's kind of loose and
it's
we have some plans but they're not like
detailed oh yeah not detailed
you know we kind of yeah you're right
just but it's because of like the nature
of content creation like it's
it's not something you can easily plan
for
maybe i'll i might do a neutral on this
one i don't know
i'm going to do a slight i might i might
also yeah
just because yeah and i think it would
be different because it's
about the detailed it's not the detailed
i think of
big picture thoughts frequently but
that's brainstorms and that's ideas and
like that's like
prepping pathways in my brain and stuff
like that i'm not setting detailed paths
i'm always like curiously
wondering which way things are going to
branch yeah
you know and that's just really hard to
do yeah so i think we're both slight
disagree on that
you rarely dwell on your regrets i'm
going to say
medium or strong i'm going to say a
strong degree i don't yeah i don't
really think about my
regrets yeah i'm strong spending time in
a dynamic atmosphere with lots of people
around quickly makes you feel drained
and in the need to get away
yes i'm going to do like a medium agree
i'm going to do a medium agree
i want to do a slider maybe yeah
because like it we do recharge around
each other if it's just us or just the
two of us we recharge
around lots of people we drain but
quickly
yeah oh i'm a slight degree yeah i think
quickly because like i think about like
events and stuff which are super fun but
then after two days we're so dead yeah
but we can last
two days that's decent for a lot of
people some people
can't even last half of a day that's
true you know
yeah there's also like being drained but
then you keep going anyway
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're right because
that that's strongly yes yeah
you see yourself as more of a realist
than a visionary
it's interesting because i i do i'm a
visionary realist
yeah i do think of myself as being more
realist but then like
again because of the nature of what we
do for work and the fact that it's
not something that many people
are able to do and i feel very lucky
that we are able to do
it then it it's like we're we're not
living in
a realistic i'm in the disagree camp i'm
not sure where
because like if we were realists would
we have ever started a youtube channel
yeah exactly
no even though i tend to think of myself
as a realist yeah i don't think we would
have started the youtube channel
and we keep on coming up with crazy
youtube videos
and we have a huge list of even more
yeah disagree
i'm really torn on this one yeah because
when it comes to our career
like i am more on the visionary side
but just for a lot of other things about
life i feel like i'm more realist
like i am more practical about things so
it's like
like your day-to-day like our usual
day-to-day decisions we're not like
coming up with visionary meal ideas or
meal
i don't know i think some of our recipes
are pretty visionary oh yeah
um but what is our day it's work
for most of it but i feel like
and what else i don't know but i feel
like the one that's like
you know if all we get done today is
filming the intro that's totally fine
and if we get done more
great you know or yeah like
um i don't know but that's
practicalness not a yeah
realist is a hard term to define
define realist
a person who accepts this the situation
is as it is and it's prepared to deal
with it accordingly
that makes it so i was thinking of it
like
synonymous with being practical
yeah but i feel like i don't necessarily
always accept the situation
because we often try to make it better
yeah like
pretty actively yeah maybe i
maybe i'm a dis on the disagree side
i'm going to do a light disagree light
disagree yeah i am going to be
medium disagree yeah you're farther on
that okay yeah because
we don't accept things as they are no
because we would never have quit our
jobs
no yeah and we're always striving to
push even farther
okay cool this is fun yeah i'm enjoying
this
you find it easy to empathize with a
person who has gone through something
you never have
i'm going to do slider medium to medium
medium i'm going to do a medium agree
too
your personal work style is closer to
spontaneous burst of energy
than to organizing consistent efforts
i'm gonna
medium or strong yeah i think that's
strong disagree
yeah we're pretty organized and
consistent yeah just because we're
working all the time it can't it has to
be consistent
yeah yeah okay next oh ninety percent
yes your emotions control you more than
you control them
no i'm on the disagree side i'll do
medium yeah
we we control our emotions but we we do
feel them but we are in control
yeah after a long and exhausting week a
fun party is just what you need
strong disagree i'm a strong disagree
it's like maybe it would be different in
like in college you know
i don't know we need we i i would
personally need recharge before i went
to a fun party yeah that's a good point
yeah i'm gonna be a strong disagree
yeah you frequently find yourself
wondering how technological advancement
could change everyday life
oh baby that's you strong strong cagry
i'm stronger than strong it's strong
it's drunk
i don't i don't really think about that
a ton honestly oh i think about it
every day i know you do almost every day
it's like i think about you know things
that are in terms of our career like i
think about how
like content creation is gonna change
everyday life or like the internet
and stuff but not really like
technological advancement
i might be a slight disagree or a medium
disagree
but the internet is technology
yeah i don't know
i don't know but when i think about
technol technological advancement
yeah it's not something you frequently
contemplate probably
medium media i think about medium
disagree yeah
you always consider how your actions
might affect other people before doing
something
so that's definitely strong degree side
yeah really strong agree
i think and i think i might be a strong
agree
i might be a medium because i am more
impulsive you are yeah you are live
i'll be medium you still honor the
commitments you have made even if you
have a change of heart
strongly yeah you rarely feel
insecure um
i mean again if it was past i would be
so this rarely i would be on the
disagree
side but right now like i don't often
feel insecure about things
medium agreement i agree yeah
yeah wait see results oh my gosh this is
it
are you ready i'm ready okay so just to
summarize
i remember i there's the four categories
analysts diplomats sentinels and
explorers
within those each of those there's four
more categories
and then i'm looking at this right now
and i'm looking back at the thing
the yellow blue i think that it is this
they just categorize
it differently so i'm on your past test
on my past test i'm gonna explore
sentinel
don't don't don't you might not be
anymore don't look at your past one yet
people can't even see that okay so
um again i think you like my guess was
that you were an explorer
one of those categories observant and
prospecting personality types known for
their spontaneity ingenuity and
flexibility and my guess was that i was
a sentinel
observant judging personality types no
for the practicality focus on order
security and stability you might also be
an analyst
i might be an analyst yeah i'm i'm i'm
you know you're an explorer
or do you think you're i'm an i'm an
analyst or explorer more likely explorer
you are a sentinel or an analyst okay
shall we
before shall we see our results yes
what
[Music]
you were green what's the i'm green and
i
am a okay i'm a
blue i want some blue i don't remember
oh i'm going by the colors okay this is
crazy i didn't expect this so you are an
advocate
an infj dash a i am a diplomat
a diplomat that's like uh that's none of
us were expecting that okay
oh and i was right i am sentinel i'm a
diplomat i'm a defender
isfj-a
that's interesting okay so
so let's let's let's read what it says
like you know in the
overall high level overall it says i'm
an advocate
quiet and mystical yet very
inspiring and tireless idealist i don't
think you're quiet
or mystical what what is it what's my
high level
defender is is defined as
very dedicated and warm protector always
ready to defend their loved ones
i don't know if i don't know if i agree
wow okay so um
it it it categorizes so on the mind
spectrum here scroll up there's even
more info like that's still here
oh okay so on the mind side i'm
60 percent introverted it says i'm 78
introverted you're more introverted than
i am supposedly okay on the
intuitive slash observance scale which
is the energy scale
74 intuitive i am 62
observant so so far we're opposite
no no no no we're both introverted
you're more introverted than i am yeah
i'm way more intuitive and you're way
more observant
on the nature side we're both very
highly feeling instead of thinking
and just to like because if you just say
nature that doesn't make sense
so all right so let's go through like so
mind it says this trait determines how
we interact with our environment yeah so
we're both on the introverted scale side
of the scale with me slightly more yeah
energy this trait shows how we direct
our mental energy
which i'm trying to intuitive or
intuitive versus observant makes sense
it's like you're observing oh i guess
intuitive
is like you look in you look inward and
observe it you look
outwards to observe on the nature side
so on energy we were opposite
yeah on nature this trait determines how
we make decisions and cope with emotions
so we're more on the feeling than the
thinking which is like
which is kind of weird because i think
that like
80 86 feeling i don't know i feel like i
use a lot of logic
yeah that's
that's crazy like i i am unsure about
this
i'm unsure too tactics this trait
reflects our approach to work planning
and decision making
you are 58 judging i am
so 85 judging versus prospecting i don't
really
understand this is like our approach to
work planning and decision making
i don't really understand like what
judging versus prospecting like
identity this trait underpins all others
showing how confident we are in our
abilities and decisions you are 74
assertive and i am 75 assertive so we're
the same on that one
this is weird this is weird this is
weird okay i'm gonna read more about the
defender personality types
the defender personality type is quite
unique as many of their qualities defy
the definition of their individual
traits through since
those sensitive defenders have excellent
analytical abilities though reserved
they have well-developed people skills
and robust social relationships and
though they are generally conservative
type
defenders are often receptive to change
in new ideas
as with so many things people with the
defender personality types are more than
the sum of the parts
and it is the way they use these
strengths to define who's that's such a
cop-out
yeah it's kind of like you're sensitive
but you're analytical
you're reserved but you have people
skills there's covering everything
[Music]
there's hardly a better type to make
such a large proportion
of the population nearly 13 combining
the best
of tradition and desire to do good
defenders are found in lines of work
with a sense of history behind them such
as medicine academics or charitable
social work
okay let me read uh mine
the advocate personality type is very
rare making up less than one percent of
the population but they nonetheless
leave their mark on the world
advocates have an inborn sense of
idealism and morality but what sets them
apart is that they are not idle dreamers
these individuals are capable of making
concrete steps to realize their goals
and make lasting positive impact
people with this personality type tend
to see helping others as their purpose
in life
advocates can often be found engaging in
rescue efforts and doing charity work
however their real passion
is to get to the heart of the issues
that people need not be rescued at all
oh man it's like i won't say defenders
they're
they're meticulous to the point of
perfectionism but then it says they
procrastinate i would never progress
never they can always be relied to get
the job done
on time that is true yes and i do go
above and beyond defenders take their
responsibilities personally
i do consistently going above and beyond
true
doing everything they can to exceed
expectations and delight it's like some
things are right and this this uh
this this parrot this this
page that we're taking to is is quite
strong because like we have an
introduction and then strength and
weaknesses and then romantic
relationships and then friendships then
parenthood
career paths workplace habits conclusion
oh that's that's too much to eat there's
so much to read
that's a lot yeah advocates indeed
share a unique combination of traits
though soft-spoken
they have very strong opinions and will
fight tirelessly for an idea they
believe in they are decisive and
strong-willed
but rarely use that energy for personal
gain
oh i kind of we're kind of focused on
growing the youtube growing the youtube
channel
adam kids will act with creativity
imagination conviction and sensitivity
not to create an advantage but to create
balance
egalitarianism and karma are very
attractive and
attractive ideals to advocate
personalities these types tend to
believe that nothing
would help the world so much as using
love and compassion to soften the hearts
of tyrants
i mean i like love and compassion but i
wouldn't say either of us
are like like i wouldn't say that you're
you go
out of your way no to like
i don't know like get involved in like
local politics or something you know
like that seems like the kind of thing
an advocate would do yeah
advocates find it easy to connect with
others they have a talent for warm
sensitive language speaking in human
terms rather than pure logic in fact
it makes sense that their friends and
colleagues would come to think of them
as a quiet
as quite extroverted personality types
quiet extroverted however they could
do well to remember that advocates need
time alone to decompress and recharge
and not to become too alarmed when they
suddenly withdraw advocates take great
care and others feelings
and they expect favor to be returned
sometimes that means giving them space
they need for a few days
so i don't
there's so much to read on these i don't
know if we
how far we should go into it we could
look at some specific ones like
romantic relationships romantic or like
workplace habits
yeah yeah we can skip over a lot of
these things
but yeah this is this is like a lot and
like
i feel i feel bad saying this
like we just took this long quiz it's so
funny
but and this is something that we can
dive into another day
but remember when we were reading our
horoscopes oh yeah our horoscopes were
much more
our horoscope types i i still have the
page pulled up with those very accurate
horoscopes there it is
no no we should do a whole nother
podcast on yeah let's not read it now
yeah we're not going to read it we'll
we'll say but it is interesting like
this like
arbitrary like you know we just happened
to be born in this month
personality when i read my personality
type on that website and then
like mine was spot on caitlyn's was
fairly dang close yeah much closer than
these personality types which is funny
because we just spent like an hour going
through this quiz and it's tough because
you know with a lot of these things
they're just saying nice things and you
see yourself in those descriptions well
i think it's like that with a lot of
like zodiac
you know signs and stuff too true
although like
yeah i don't know it's the kind of thing
where if you see something that's right
you're like oh yeah
me and if it's not right you're like you
know
i think it's it's interesting because
with
with these with a personality type
i think that there's an internal and
external component of it
does that make sense let me try to
define that better
there's how you
think internally versus how you live
your life
externally yeah and i think a lot of
what i kind of disagree with
in terms of the advocate personality
is the other side of things
i i like and maybe it's just the word
they chose
but what reading the advocate it's like
a lot of like
going out and doing all these things in
this world
whereas like i think internally
and externally i'm more on the like
explorer side
of yes with the experimenter and master
of all tools and
like artists and entrepreneur and
entertainer and stuff like that
yeah i mean that is the summary of what
we do externally but neither of us got
an explorer personality type
yeah which is interesting
yeah but it's hard because like we do
this externally but we enjoy it
internally yeah um
do you want to pull up your old
personality test yeah so my old
personality test
from how many years ago nine nine years
ago i am a person who enjoys and thrives
on having people around me
my focus though will be on the others
not me i have a naturally warm
disposition and people are generally
comfortable opening up to me i have a
natural desire to help others even while
doing volunteer work for organizations
that allow me to hate others
i love parties
it just says i love parties does that
that single word the single line
i am creative and in some cases
musically oriented i am adept at
starting and sustaining harmonious
relationships i am tolerant
understanding supportive and a natural
listener i love life and i love people
when it says
um you're musically oriented and then it
says starting and sustaining harmonious
i was like
harmonies are you gonna sing some
harmonies for us i have an inherent
desire to help
people and i have to be aware that this
built-in need could get me hurt or even
killed
jeez i find it virtually impossible to
stop myself from jumping in and helping
someone this personality
type is like saying the same thing as
the
advocate i mean you do like
helping people
i mean maybe there's different types of
it maybe if you think of it this way
like
like putting out the content we put out
into the world we do help that it or we
do hope that it like makes
someone's day brighter that is oh we
hope that someone maybe like
like picks up a tip or trick that makes
them
feel more confident and like tackling a
project or
trying something new you know maybe
that's that's just a different type of
helping someone
that's a little bit more to the side of
the definition
that which like yours was like going out
and advocating mine was like doing
charity work
that's not really you like that's kind
of the more
straightforward definition but maybe if
you think of it
as just like wanting to make other
people's day
better maybe that does apply more
i don't know yeah that's interesting
should we read the romantic
relationships so to close it out
sure when it comes to romantic
relationships
advocates take the process of finding a
partner seriously
that's true that's true not one for
casual encounters true
people with the advocate personality
type and should look for depth and
meaning in their relationships advocates
will take the time necessary to find
someone with whom they truly connect
once they have found that someone their
relationship will reach levels of depth
and sincerity
of which most people can only dream
getting to that point can sometimes be a
challenge for
potential partners especially if they
are impatient types advocates
are often perfectionistic and picky
people with this personality type aren't
easily talked
into something that they don't want if
someone doesn't pick up on that they are
unlikely to be forgiven particularly in
the early stages of dating
even worse is if their partner tries to
resort to manipulating or lying oh no
oh no if there's anything they have a
poor tolerance for in a relationship
it's lack of authenticity
i mean on the relationship side of
things that's pretty spot-on
so mine is when it comes to romantic
relationships
the defender's kindness grows into a joy
that can only
that is only found in taking care of
their family and home
being there for emotional and practical
support whenever needed
home is where the heart is for people
with the defender personality type and
in no other area of their lives they
strive with such dedication to create
the harmony and beauty they wish to see
in the world that was like a big
sentence of nothing
yeah mine was much more concrete
yeah this is like this sounds kind of
like you know the love languages like
acts of service
yeah like doing things around the house
to show
that you love the person that's like
or like taking care of others
or keep on reading the trouble is these
are benefits of an established long-term
relationship and the defender's
unbearable shyness
means it can take a long time to reach
this point defenders are most attractive
when they are simply being themselves in
a comfortable environment such as work
where their natural flow shows the
kindness and dedication relationships
built on established familiarity are a
warm prospect for defenders
they take dating seriously and only
enter into relationships that have a
real chance of lasting a lifetime
so we we match on that well like yeah
like
only the last word was something
concrete only the last sentence
was something like a little more
concrete i think what i was trying to
say
is like you're awkward
for dating and like you want to get to
that point of comfort in a relationship
where you're just like living together
and in your pjs
that's i got some of that out of this
like
defenders are most attractive when they
are simply being themselves in a
comfortable environment
work where their natural flow shows this
kind of and how it was like
like the things you want are the
benefits of an established long-term
relationship
but my unbearable shyness can mean it
can take a long time to reach that point
see with me and you we never went
through like an awkward relationship
phase we were already really comfortable
around each other so if i'm
interpreting that as my brain wants to
interpret it maybe there's
are some accuracies because i do
like just being like comfortable and
cozy
with you at home as opposed to like
you know the like dating phases of like
trying to
find someone to be in a relationship
with like
you know okay so i went to the
conclusion just to see if this thing can
save itself
and i i think that this is like kind of
interesting this is like pinging a few
things for me
few personality types are as passionate
and mysterious as advocates
i don't get the whole mysterious thing i
don't think i don't think i'm that
mysterious
at all i'm pretty much out there but
this
as someone with this personality type
your imagination and empathy make you
someone who
cherishes their integrity and deeply
held principles
that that's more on math unlike many
other idealistic types however
you are also capable of turning those
ideals and into plans and executing that
is true that's true
yet advocates can easily be tripped up
in areas where their idealism and
determination are more of a liability
than an
asset i'm not sure what would that be
there are many areas in life where you
face challenges that at times you can
you may even question who you really are
anything from navigating interpersonal
conflicts confronting unpleasant facts
pursuing self-realization or finding
career path that aligns well with your
inner core
can cause internal frustration i feel
like you have a pretty good idea of who
you are
finding a career path that lined up with
who i am that was tough
that was tough i found it and i really
feel good being here but
i mean you did you have done a lot of
self analysis i did a lot of self
analyzing but i feel like
you kind of know who you are now so
again some of this is hard because it's
like past you versus present
yeah overall i'm gonna wrap mine up i'm
not gonna read that whole conclusion
that's too long
yeah but like you know overall i'm gonna
say
you know in terms of like how i connect
with their conclusions
i give it like a fifty percent yeah
maybe like a
sixty percent it i i don't feel like it
captured me
i just don't feel like it really
captured me that much at all i feel the
same
i'm curious like those of you who are
who have taken this
and are more familiar with the
personality types i'm curious
one if you took it did you find that it
was accurate and two
do you think that there's another
personality type that fits us better
yeah yeah i'm curious also is there a
better personality test
this is like a big one this is this is
like one of the biggest ones
infj i i
like another thing that i could do is
like there's just 16 personality types
should we just read through all of them
and see which one we'd
relate with the most instead of it like
there's that's too much to read
too much we're already an hour and 17.
no no no
like as an alternative method instead of
taking it
like you mean for another podcast no no
just for fun
oh like not like during a podcast just
just like
as a way to figure out uh maybe
i think with what personality tests are
supposed to do art
like because you can you can read
something and be like yeah that one's me
but then it doesn't line up with your
actual actions oh
yeah so it's supposed to provide
something hidden inside
yeah it's supposed to like show you
hidden insights where you can't like
rig your own answers to try oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so instead of
just like keeping yourself in your own
like
bubble of like i think i'm this but
really you're this no but
that's why i ask you more about like
your thoughts and actions i think it's
tough though because as like the test
has proven and as we know we analyze a
lot we think about ourselves maybe we
over thought those questions
maybe we overthought those questions
yeah maybe well hey it's been going for
a bit you want to do our thing of the
week yeah yeah this has been a long one
let's do our thing of the week okay
my thing of the week is uh
animated series on netflix called the
dragon prince
it is this is recommended to us on our
discord yeah and it is uh
it's so good it's so good it it it has
the right balance of like
humor and like
good story it has the right balance of
um
episodic versus series you know it's
like
you know there are little side
adventures but it's all along
like a good path it's all it's all like
part of one big overarching story
across the three seasons good character
development good
you know no no not like there's almost
no flat
personality types everyone is very
interesting
interesting and and those are things
that we all like so it's been fun
yeah it's really good i'm sad we're on
season i know
there's only three seasons tonight i
want good stuff to last longer
well since we haven't finished it i mean
maybe it'll leave on like a cliffhanger
that makes us think like oh maybe
there's gonna be more
i don't know i don't know either i don't
think that it will no
maybe it'll be so successful that they
have to do more well like at the same
time
that's dangerous they're going to have
to have a new
like story arc and will that story arc
be worthy of
additional i don't know it's just not
one more dragon prince
i know i just wish they had like had
extended and made this
five seasons instead yeah more more with
more side adventures
yet still like on the same arc because
they were
so anyways yeah i don't want to go into
all of the animated series we've watched
but we we finished
avatar the last airbender and that's sad
and then that was a while back we uh
watched which wasn't as good as it you
know
some parts some parts were enjoyable
some parts were like
well like it's so interesting analyzing
it
after we finished quora we found out
that the
nickelodeon wouldn't fund
all of the seasons at once they had to
do it one series at a time once
or one season at a time and i can see
that restriction
in the storytelling that's why there's
like the bad guy of the month
yeah but i really liked cora but i
didn't like that there wasn't a big
overarching story
i didn't like that there weren't enough
moments where characters could develop
on little side quests and stuff
and i feel like the the i feel like they
were unfairly restricted
by their their season-by-season funding
i feel like they were kind of like it
could have it could have been better if
it could have been more
if nickelodeon had bought like a few
seasons yeah
that's my main trouble with it um
yeah which i guess maybe is one of the
benefits of like it seems like
netflix shows sometimes
maybe i'm just thinking this because
they're released all at once
but it seems like more are um
purchased or whatever all at once which
gives the writers
the ability to do these bigger
overarching storylines yeah
okay my thing of the week is the foam
smith three book
so um our friends bill and bit
bill and britt from punished props um
they've done
two oh you have it yay they've done two
foam smith books and this is the third
it just came out the
third one's all about like helmets and
crowns and headgear and masks and stuff
and so we have their first two and and
besides the fact that they're just
awesome people that we enjoy and they're
our friends
yeah the the books are super helpful
like
we i know we haven't we haven't done any
we haven't done
many like cosplay or costume type stuff
but um when we were first starting the
like wonder woman
stuff especially the bracers which were
foam
the the books were super helpful just
like all these little techniques that
you wouldn't
necessarily think about like one of my
favorites is
if you want to do scratch marks you do a
very light score
on the foam with the exacto knife and
then you heat gun it and they kind of
naturally open in a way that looks so
cool
but there's all these like cool little
tips and tricks and what they do with
foam
is magical so um if you are
looking if you're interested in like
costumes or props or cosplay
or you want to make like a super crazy
halloween costume who knows if
halloween's even happening this year i
don't know
don't think about it too much cost you
um definitely check it out
we'll have a link um and there are
awesome people to support and you'll get
like a really cool book
and they've been working on this book
for years i believe
yeah i don't know the exact time a long
time long time yeah
it's sweet i want to read through it
right now i know we just got in the mail
so we haven't had a chance to read
through this one but
i've read the first two and they're very
helpful very helpful
and they wrote a nice little message i
know
we love you guys alrighty um that was a
long
podcast yep um let us know what you
think
we're gonna go eat lunch and uh we'll
look forward to seeing you
in the next podcast do i say that on the
podcast i don't know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bye